[Music]
how's it going with my name HP oppa
welcome to extremely noisy Italian
outdoor freaking cars there's a lot of
stuff to talk about this Friday so I'm
just gonna get right into it before yep
this is gonna be terrible anyway the
first thing I wanted to say is I've been
on teens react that's why this Bronner
me got 1 million eight hundred thousand
subscribers and we were like 1 million
six hundred thousand scribe it's crazy
that I really got a lot of promotion
seriously it's a it's a great deal to be
featured on that side it obviously means
that we you and we come really far
breath so I'm really proud of it if you
haven't check out the video go ahead and
click on cool guy right now
it should open it I knew a tab if it's
working or not
yeah you should subscribe to his channel
as well they upload a lot of high
quality stuff so it's really good but
yeah also don't be offended if anyone
has like a different opinion about me I
suddenly certainly don't quite give a
shite and I don't think you both should
care either I think it's okay for people
to have a pinion even though you're
[ __ ] wrong you barrels
I'm just kidding right poga right she
spit in my face nice what else
a of course the charity thing as you may
or may not know last week I started a
charity event for in hopes of using my
famous yeah it sounds so stupid I know
but the fact that I'm a public person a
little oh I can't talk okay go go in my
face talked for me we started a charity
thing to help kids with cancer or other
diseases and it III really really
heartwarming to see I met being really
cheesy for your birthday today but
seriously I never expected so many so
much support from you bros and it was
just awesome to see like we gathered
together so many [ __ ] cars we gather
gather 32,000 dollars we she's insane
it's so much money and I'm really glad
that we're putting it to good use and I
feel proud of you breast I feel proud of
that you know not only that we
accomplished something really awesome
but also because I feel like you bros
have my back you know if something if I
asked you bros for help then you deliver
and I really appreciate that and that
was also why I was so I was so happy to
see that somebody wanted to support this
cause with me I will show a video where
I donate the money soon so don't worry
it's for kind of fun a hug you can't
literally do nothing without people
hating me for you I'm trying to do
charity and people like you see it's
gonna keep the money for himself or like
he's just taking credit for what other
people doing this is something that you
breast it and I'm just organizing it so
this is really all credits to the bro
army really but yeah I'm really I'm why
can't stress how happy I am about this I
will definitely do more charity stuff in
the future I think like I said this
shows how awesome you bros really are so
I'm really happy and I'm if anything I'm
just really proud anyway that's the
final thing that I want to say is lately
I've been noticing a lot of people
saying like oh I wish Peter Blair was
more serious I wish
you know it's I wish Pete if I would
joke more and then people say like oh
it's getting boring and then I try to
jerk more and people like oh you gotta
be serious and it's like I'm just
playing games I like to play games
it's I'm definitely all for constructive
traces criticism and you bros can say
whatever you want you know Peter you
should fix this and you should try to
read more dialog and stuff like that but
just saying act a certain way is kind of
weird I kind of feel like I'm just
playing how I like to play and if you're
telling me to act a certain way or do
something then that ruins edge in my
opinion and it's kind of annoying for
people to keep saying oh we should do
this and do that
like I said all for cuz god damn it
seriously so I hope you bros understand
where I'm coming from I think that was
pretty much all I had to say again I
can't stress how happy I am about the
charity thing again stay awesome bros
but I know you you know it's obvious all
right you ready for this hi Perry what
you talk now that's where everything
just talks okay sales and bears
[Music]